hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible attacking game from this
year's Dubai open uh this is round two
and we've just finished with charger but
now most of the players are playing in
Dubai they had like a one day rest and
now they have to play a grueling
tournament again it's a nine round Swiss
tournament uh 90 minutes per player you
know plus 30 seconds increments are
pretty standard normal classical
tournament and here we have Han smoking
Eamon facing a very strong Buzzard by
Johnny Grandmaster uh who got a sadly
there's a bit of a rating difference but
that makes the games all the more
interesting now my camera has died a
little bit but it returned so that's
great so let's check it out and see uh
What uh what happened here so Hans with
the white pieces opens with Pawn to D4
we have Knight to F6 uh sorry about that
uh and uh Pawn to C4 uh so pretty
standard stuff we have knight uh uh we
have Bishop to G6 Knight the C3 and
Bishop to G7 the king's Indian defense
is on the board uh E4 and D6 with Pawn
to H3 the makagon of variation and now
Pawn to E5 asking whites to advance the
pawn to D5 uh White of course does that
as you don't want to trade queens and
now Pawn to A5 and now okay it's a
pretty standard line you know the Knight
is coming on A6 then maybe it's a B4
maybe to C5 you might have access that
the D4 Pawn you might have access the D3
might even have access to B3 all depends
on what the white plays with Bishop to
E3 uh and now Knight to A6
um
continues the the knights Journey Knight
to F3 and now uh usually you will see uh
castles and knights the C5 here but we
have Bishop to D7 which has only been
played once uh and now there is a game
the the one that I mentioned where the
D3 was played it was played last last
year or maybe in 2012 yeah in 2022
between uh Lucas Farm forest and
kiroshvchenko uh that ended by winning
but instead we have uh Pawn to G4 and it
is now as of move nine that we have a
completely new game so let's see what
happens here Knights the C5 uh sorry
about that uh
sorry about that
um he he doesn't come you know the
entire day and then as soon as I start
recording he just arrives but okay
Knight the C5 at least you had time to
study the position properly uh Queen to
C2 with Queen to E7 and now both players
Castle but here we have Castle's Queen
side uh and uh vulgar goes for Castle's
King side so now okay you have castles
on opposite sides of the board obviously
there's gonna be some attacking going on
but it's very hard for Hans to actually
attack the black king as um okay you
know that the queen will come to this
diagonal you're probably going to want
to trade off the dark Square Bishops um
but how do you advance the pawn you
can't play H4 at any point as the G4
Pawn would hang so here we have Bishop
to E2 uh standard moves here that you
will want to play uh include King to B1
uh Bishop T2 and then at some point uh
start some sort of an attack on the king
side but here we have Bishop D2 First
Pawn to A4 and now Hansa needs to decide
whether he wants to allow Pawn to A3 or
not if you allow it um well you could
play something like King to B1 and then
after point a three B3 so it's possible
to play something like this then Rook F
to B8 then B5 comes and uh well uh you
know it's uh it's a possibility but Hans
decides to play A3 so he stops A3 uh by
vulgar but now he allows Knight to B3
check and okay it could be a preferable
uh King to B1 and now Pawn to C5
advancing that pawn and you know that
now B5 is coming or first is going to be
prepared so Hans captures uh on C6 Alpha
song b captures and now Queen to D3
putting pressure on that D6 spawn but
now Knights the D4 vulgar sacrifices the
first of many pawns that will be offered
this game Knight captures on D4 uh e
captures Bishop captures and now Pawn to
C5 trying to chase the bishop back but
the problem is if you go back with the
bishop then the E4 Pawn will become weak
let's take Bishop to C6 and yes you can
play one to F3 it's very nice you wanna
Pawn but then Rook have to B8 and for
the price of one Pawn black gets a very
nice attack black and blue Rook to B3
then double up on the B file
uh doesn't look like something you want
to play so instead after C5 Bishop
captures and C6 hunts gives up the dark
Square Bishop Queen captures and now
Queen captures on D6 so Hans wins the
second Pawn but he's now down a dark
Square Bishop so there is only one move
if you don't want to trade Queens
because
um well the queen and the bishop are
under attack so Bishop to E6 and now
Hans just grabs another pawn queen
captures and C5 and I'll give you grab
three pawns uh if um you don't get
checkmated of course you are winning
this game so you can Hans avoid being
checkmated
uh Rook fwba by vulgar and now Hans
needs to decide the problem is and of
course now Rook after B8 as soon as it
was played it introduced the threat of
Queen captures on C3 now the B Pawn is
pinned the problem is if you just
sidestep this thread you run into this
threat Rook captures and B2 with
checking capture screen captures and C3
check and of course you get checkmated
so a pretty standard stuff so Hans gives
the back one Pawn plays Pawn to E5 uh in
hopes of trading Queens because okay he
gives up one point he trades Queens he's
still up to pawns uh in an end game so
Queen to F4 now of course we're gonna
declines this uh Knight the B5 now very
nicely closing of the B file and now
Bishop captures an E5 with Queen to E3
offering a trade as the queen and the
bishop are attacked but just Queen F6
booger can defend his Bishop from F6 uh
G5 now trying to kick away the queen and
the bishop to F5 with check with Bishop
to D3 uh not Bishop captures but first
queen to E6 and now Bishop captures an
F5 Queen captures also comes with check
and now Queen to D3 offering a queen
trade but not just Queen captures and G5
so winning back some material and now
Hans is only up one Pawn but okay he
still survived the attack we have Queen
to C2 and now Bishop to F6 we have
rooked the D7 uh getting the Rook into
the attack uh and here we have Queen to
F4 there was a very tricky move here
that sort of wins the game for Ruger but
it's not an easy one to spot Bishop
captures some B2 was that on your on
your spidey sense because after Bishop
captures on B2 there's no good way to to
reply to this if you play King capture
sunbeat or even worse if Queen captures
then just Queen to F5 check picks up the
Rook on D7 uh so you're gonna have to
capture with the King but now Rook
captures on B5 with check and the
problem maybe it was considered maybe it
wasn't is that it's very hard to meet
this root captures on B5 Checker the
problem is if you capture uh then just
Queen captures and B5 check again picks
up the Rook on D7 and then you're just I
mean you have um okay it's not it's not
the worse than a material a disadvantage
you're only down upon but your king is
wide in the open I mean if this Rook
ever comes to B3 and there's just no
playing this so uh the the only thing
you could do here is that after this row
captures some B5 check you don't
recapture just clicking day two and now
it's uh you know maybe you can survive
this but after Rook B3 just looks really
really bad I mean if the black queen
somehow gets access to the A3 Pawn for
the moment you can't do it because all
of these squares are covered also the E7
square is covered but at some point
you're gonna probably be able to do it
and um
should be just straight out winning for
for black so yeah Bishop capture some B2
definitely a great move but Queen to F4
was played and now Rook H the D1 hunt
gets his other Rook into the game with
Rook to A6 uh and now Rook the C1 here
uh Hans uh struggles finding a viable
plan Rook to D6 looks like something you
might want to want to do trying to offer
a rook trade and also putting pressure
on the bishop here but he plays The Rook
to C1 and now we have Rook the C6
putting pressure on the on the pawn here
probably why Rook the C1 was played to
add additional support to the C4 Pawn
Rook to D5 and now we have Bishop to G5
and here uh the thread of course is
Queen captures and C1 just winning the
exchange and what Hans should play is
Rook the G1 here but it's such a
difficult move to spawn because if Rook
to G1 look at this Rook captures on C4
of course okay everyone sees that uh
Rook to G4 is the idea this is the best
way for white to continue the the game
without just losing terribly any four
captures on C2 Rook captures an effort
now you're gonna grab another Pawn just
you know for good measure and now Bishop
captures an F4 you're going to be up
upon and you know you probably will not
win this game but you do have chances of
winning this game uh so you know it
would be the best uh course of action
for Hans but Hans uh decided to go for
Rook captures on G5 he gives up the
exchange to win back uh some more
material and now it's very very exciting
Queen captures on G5 Queen captures on
A4 and now Queen to F5 with check Rook
the C2 and queen captures on H3 yeah so
now if you count to the material okay
um uh booger is up the exchange but Hunt
is up upon if if he can start pushing
those Queen side pawns uh could be very
dangerous but of course not with so much
Firepower on the board so Knights the D4
attacks the rook and now Rook the D6
attacks the Knight and here Hans starts
advancing the pawn pawn to C5 the Knight
is nicely defended if he can get his C
Pawn to C7 and that's going to be worth
at least an exchange however C5 is
actually uh what loses the game for hunt
but it's not easy to spot why so feel
free to pause the video and try to win
the game for vulgar while I give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding this
wild maneuver and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is of
course Queen to F1 with check another
video where our winning strategy starts
with check but it's not easy to see why
and the the reason is that after King
the A2 uh there's this very very cool
Rook to A6 idea and after the queen
moves you're just gonna play Rook
captures on A3 you give up a full Rook
now you can't capture with the pawn if
you capture with the pawn queen to B1 is
checkmates you're gonna have to capture
with the King but it's not much better
Queen to A1 with check Queen has to
block and now of course just Rook the A8
check will pick up the White Queen
doesn't matter where the King goes real
characters or queen captures and of
course it's game over so the real
question is what happens
um after this uh uh after this queen
Tafe uh F1 check if Rook the C1 is
played as it was played in the game Hans
of course did not go for King day two
Hans played Rook to C1 uh the real move
is not the one that vugar played we're
gonna play Queen captures and F2 the
real movies Queen to D3 with check
because disconnects with the Knight and
if the Knight goes back Knights the C2
now you play Rook to D5 and uh there's
uh just not all that much white can play
here for example if C6 you're gonna play
Rook to C5 and that's that's pretty much
it white is white is other moves however
Queen captures on F2 was played instead
and now we have Knight to B5 attacking
The Rook on D6 uh the the way to defend
this queen to city with Queen to C2
probably you can still fight for example
Queen captures Knight captures you of
course you have to move the Knight now
Rook D5 attacks the pawn and if Knight
before attacking The Rook Rook the D2
and now of course if C6 King to f8 C7
Rook to C8 and you don't really have to
worry there's no way to punish the the
roof for being UNCA there's no easy way
to attack it with the Knight you need
too many moves and black is just uh well
we'll be winning here so instead after
Queen captures and F2 Knights the B5 was
played and now Rook to D2 putting
pressure from the B2 pawn queen to B3
defending and now Rook the E8 preparing
to Triple up on the second rank uh
Knight the D6 attacking the rook and
just The Rook e to E2 and how do you
defend now the only move is Knight to C4
but now Queen to F5 with check King to
A2 and now Queen captures on C5 so Hans
loses his precious C5 Pawn but it was
necessary in order to prevent getting
checkmated so uh now you you can't
really capture if you capture then you
just trade down into a losing end game
so Rook the C3 uh Hans His Last Stand
but now Rook back to d8 we have Pawn to
A4 uh Hans tries pushing the pawn uh
Rook to E1 we have Knights to B6 now
yeah and queen to G1 going after Rook
the A1 Checkmate Queen to B5 now freeing
up the A3 Square for the white king but
now it's officially a king hunt Rook to
A1 with check King B3 Queen to D1 with
check knocking the B4 and now Rook the
B1 preparing to win the the pawn in the
game so Knight to C4 and now Queen to D4
uh pinning the Knight so now Rook
captures on B2 is once again a threat
Pawn to B3 and now Queen to F4 we have
Queen to E5 trying to trade Queens here
and even though you could do this and
still win the game there's no reason to
do it Rook to beat a with check King to
A3 now Rook the A1 check and this is how
you properly trade Queens not just
trading Queens into winning end game uh
training Queens into a winning end game
and snatching a pawn while you're at it
so here King to B2 and now Queen
captures an E5 Knight captures on E5 and
of course Rook captures on the A4 as the
B Pawn is pinned there's no capturing
the pawn back so now you're just up too
much material Knight the C6 was played
now it's merely a matter of how many
moves is Hans willing to make before
resigning
of course you could still play something
like Rook to see it and run into a nice
Fork but Rook to B7 is played and that's
pretty much it Knight the d8 we have
Rook to B6 and it was in this position
animal 58 that Hans moken Neiman
resigned the game and a brilliant
brilliant victory for vugar Assad who
takes down a 2700 Grand Master so very
nicely done the problem is there's no
good way to play the Knight is pretty
much trapped there's no way to go if you
try to bring the Knight back it's very
easy to win just spawn to H5 I mean you
you just bring the king in you pull the
pawns there's no counter play for white
uh if one to B4 you can even capture
this I mean you you gladly give up the
The Rook for Knight and pawn and now
you're just up three pawns and
completely winning so there are many
ways you can win this uh Hans this size
that it's best to just resign and and
and and end it there so yeah a very a
very exciting game with um as soon as I
saw castling on opposite sides and it
was going to be a wild game but uh I
mean as uh Google just started
sacrificing Pawn by Pawn Pawn first he
gives up this Central D4 Pawn then he
gives up another pawn and D6 down and C5
and Hans just couldn't take the pressure
he had to start giving back pawns but
then uh once the the material again sort
of equalized uh he ended up with a with
a worse position uh so yeah very very
nice very exciting game uh really
enjoyed it if you have any of your own
favorites from the Dubai open uh use
hashtag suggestion and I will go over
your suggestions uh so yeah that's the
game uh I hope you guys enjoyed the
story about the interruption by the
mailman and by my camera I I I'm trying
to fix this I still haven't found a
reason why it's happening I would like
to thank golfsoftware.com Marcus grabble
Anonymous MK1 and for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Dubai
open and everything else that's
happening in the Chess World so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day